welcome to the silk bulb test please
stay seated for the duration of the test
oh you prefer the color
red well compared to what right cuz like
my background's red I would say my
favorite color is actually green but I
do I do choose a lot of red I didn't
know that this would be such a toughy
off the bat um well soon as I got my my
eyes inundated with
blood all I see now is red so I guess I
do prer it true true true true true so
true bestie what I
true
oh ah I didn't notice that
oh hi
hello this must be fun for you okay um
so am I being like time is it should do
do I need to
hurry fascinating okay um I'm guessing
the top is
a you're not going to tell me you press
a a is true you love
red do
I
oh
[Music]
okay is this what I'm supposed to do or
say
ba
[Music]
ba ba ba
ba I I I did
it
[Music]
oh are you displeased I I swear I did
that
right oh I probably didn't wait long
enough how many times have I pressed it
oh okay
thank
you this is an image of a door oh oh oh
no I know a
door
that's no Jesus
Christ I'm pretty sure that's not a
door that's a
door
oh
God what you what did you say to
me
um oh there's something behind me isn't
there oh
Goodbye Oh my
God today was
special so I've Been Told
but
why that's a that's not a
clock no
no
yeah oh
yeah
[Music]
no
yeah
no it depends on if there's a phone in
the car sometimes they have
that yeah
probably no defin definitely
not you can't fool me with that
one it's technically two people so I'm
going to go
[Music]
no oh
oh I'm not going to turn
around
oh
oh whoa what did you give me you guys
having fun back there you along for the
ride you seeing what's going on
[Music]
oh H all
right
[Music]
that's
me oh is that
[Music]
good lexian zoom
Zoom Closer Closer little closer just a
little
closer let's get a good luck
Closer
Closer Closer
Closer come
on Clos all right good
thanks
nope not my
friend oh my God yeah that's my pal but
nope what's wrong with your
chin oh yeah that's a
stranger
yep oh yeah oh yeah
oh
yeah oh don't trust that do not who we
talking about who we talking about who
we talking about who who are we talking
about oh what are we talking about I'm
[Music]
looking you know the thing is you say
not to trust them I didn't trust them in
the first place I don't even know who
they are unless you're talking not about
them and talking about other things in
the don't trust them yeah
okay I breakfast this morning ah did I I
don't even remember I was up pretty late
last night I don't I don't I don't you
going to give me food or I don't I don't
I don't think I
did well it depends if I'm at a hotel
and there's like a free breakfast I'll
eat it all the time love that
I guess
yeah breakfast is overrated well I mean
I don't know if it's the most important
meal of the day the science is kind of
out on that and I don't even know who
the science is doing for that who's
doing I I what is do you have
breakfast you eating over
there you munching on a
ranola no I love
breakfast
you fear making the incorrect Choice
well well I don't know about that I
don't really care about being wrong I
care about being dead you should yeah
you you right you right you fear failure
actually that's not true that's not
true feel guilty when you're alone no
actually I I feel great feel
great then why are you
here B
you feel alone in a
[Music]
crowd what does that even mean what does
that what kind of poet poetic nonsense
is that feel alone in a
crowd I do have Sigma male energy
so yeah you are alone well I mean not
really unless you're talking about here
then definitely not really
no
[Music]
you telling me these are just
disembodied hands it would make a lot of
sense actually
but
okay I thought this was a fear the
unknown no not
really don't worry you will okay all
right Edge Lord yeah scare me
really
do I oh yep yep yep 100% wait no please
I want to please please maybe I'll use
it
next ah I
see
what oh I got to use the
w
who's
there
oh you eating over
there this guy's got
a this guy's got a granola chewing kind
of loud there
pal
you done I'm sorry are you done may I
continue
okay all right you getting
closer
oh oh
[Music]
God
I don't even know what I'm looking at
what am I looking
[Music]
at what am I looking at I don't even
know
oh
[Music]
all right
fine
H oh boy
really damn I'm
good
[Music]
oh
how got to cut that
oh don't look down so true bestie so
true
bestie oh
boy
y
y y oh y oh
y oh no wait a minute
Bo
insert hey wait a
minute
oh what what do you
mean
oh
hello
peekaboo oh come back here come back
here you little Scamp where'd you
go H oh here we
go I got you
apparently bigab
oh hello I see you sure hope someone
doesn't spring out from the darkness and
crawl up my
rectum
oh I knew it I caught you you were going
to crawl right up there weren't you oh
not today not
today have to crawl up my
front
oh today was special it sure was so true
there was oh man you
guys I cherish
this whoa calibration
oh thanks guys this is great thank you
oh
again shall ride
again when
[Applause]
did I
win did I did I
win did did I
win a no way not
me okay I'm going to get this right this
time
b
a
b a
b I did it okay I'm being such a good
sport that's not a door what happens if
the time runs
out
oh
[Music]
no wake
up I'm not going to
[Music]
look oh
hi
H hello oh uh yeah come on come on
[Music]
over
59 but I didn't do anything I did I did
literally nothing how did I get a
59 hate
[Music]
alone that's a different
question you'd rather have eaten
alone
n you fear being alone
absolutely you feel guilty when you're
alone yeah oh hello feel alone in a
crowd
no
fear the unknown
absolutely then don't look behind
you it's a leaf
blower and sorry BR whoa oh what if I
put it in the shadow down there oh
oh oh what if I put it on that shadow oh
wait wait eat me wait go back go back go
back eat me eat me eat me eat eat
me oh I'm being ingested okay this this
what if I did this
instead huh huh
huh oh I thought I was being super
clever all right so I'm back in
here the question
is what the
dealio I saw you come here you
come here you I'm going get you I'm
going get you where you
going I'm going to get you so it doesn't
really matter I think where you go today
was special oh screw
you screw
[Music]
you okay so I don't think there are
multiple endings I haven't checked on
the development page but I just had to
go through it again just in case to see
if there was something but I don't think
that there's many I don't think the
questions really make a difference CU it
seems like there are some different
questions but it seems like the
experience is going to be the same no
matter what I like the design the
Aesthetics are great the setup is very
simple obviously just two buttons and
like a little bit more and the looking
around the room and being trapped in the
middle of it it's not like the it's not
like you know completely novel but I I
love like the the Aesthetics of which it
was put so this was good I like it a lot
and I don't think that there's any
secrets but I think there's a lot of
potential here so I want to see more
definitely make more I'll put the link
to the game in the description below
thank you everybody so much for watching
have a lovely day more scary games on my
channel
everywhere right behind
you okay
goodbye